der bundestags vizepräsident hat
zwischenzeitlich einen weiteren
tagesordnungspunkt aufgerufen hier im
deutschen plenum das heißt es geht jetzt
hier auch regulär weiter es wird ja noch
ein paar wechsel in der besetzung geben
es werden es werden hier die
abgeordneten kommen die sich mit diesem
thema das jetzt aufgerufen bisher
beschäftigen als die gesamtheit des
bundestags da gibt es im grunde liegt
ein fdp-antrag es geht um die
offenlegung finanzieller lasten der
migrationspolitik und der erste redner
in dieser aussprache ist gottfried
corinna finden sich auch viele etats
verteilt was fehlt ist eine jährliche
auflistung aller kosten der politik der
offenen grenzen als transparentes
gesamtbild für den steuerzahler
wenn bei zweistelligen milliarden
ausgaben die regierung tönt niemandem
wird durch die flüchtlinge etwas
weggenommen dann ahnt der bürger dass
genau das geschieht geben euro kann man
nur einmal ausgeben denn wer darf die
ganze nation sorry sponsern der
ausgepresste steuerzahler vor dem muss
diese regierung endlich detailliert
rechenschaft ablegen die willkommens
party kostet nämlich unterbringung und
verpflegung krankenkassen und später
rente deutschkurse und dolmetscher
erfolglose abschiebe versuche nur wenige
unfassbar teure erfolgte abschiebungen
wachpersonal und polizeieinsätze
hunderttausende widerspruchsverfahren
und dann die verwaltung dieses ganzen
chaos das alles verschlingt milliarden
und zu vielen diese milliarden an
anderer stelle
der deutsche beamtenbund schlägt alarm
die öffentliche verwaltung liegt am
boden kaputt gespart systemkollaps von
baugenehmigungen bis zu gerichten
absurde wartezeiten
personal keine ausstattung
tatverdächtige müssen freigelassen
werden die infrastruktur zerfällt kita
plätze fehlen unterricht fällt aus die
leistungsträger werden vom staat
ausgepresst und bekommen nichts mehr
zurück laut hans-werner sinn kostet
schon die bisherige migrationspolitik
den steuerzahler 1000 milliarden euro
ähnlich professor raffelhüschen das
institut der deutschen wirtschaft und
das kieler institut für
wirtschaftsforschung kommen auf gut 50
milliarden pro jahr
mit einer solchen summe müssen die
bundesministerien für inneres bildung
familie umwelt finanzen zusammen
auskommen
die stiftung marktwirtschaft stellt klar
dass deutschland eben nicht profitiert
eine ungesteuerte zuwanderung bringt dem
land keine fiskalische rendite sondern
kostet dauerhaft sagt
stiftungsvorsitzender ein ford die masse
der zuwanderer meine damen wird am ende
grundsicherung im alter bekommen
steuerfinanziert das ist die realität
der zuwanderung nicht geordnet und
gesteuert sondern angeordnet und
steuerfinanziert meine damen und herren
ein funktionierender sozialstaat würde
doch vor allem die armut seiner bürger
reduzieren und die belastung der
steuerzahler senken die inländer
feindlichen ideologen dieser regierung
aber haben ganz andere prioritäten
riesige geldströme für eine absurde
energiewende die vollversorgung
hunderttausender wirtschaftsmigranten
die subventionierung anderer eu-staaten
und demnächst von ganz afrika
wir fordern priorität für die wohlfahrt
unserer bürger
statt für unberechtigte statt dauer
willkommens-party der illegalität wieder
vorfahrt für recht und vernunft
37 prozent der hartz iv leistungen gehen
ein ausländer die nur 13 prozent der
bevölkerung ausmachen
seit 2007 haben sich hartz iv-leistungen
ausländer auf 13 milliarden jährlich
verdoppelt die hartz4 wurde der
zuwanderer ist mit 60 prozent sieben mal
höher als bei der gesamtbevölkerung
diese regierung forciert zuwanderung von
leuten millionen stärke die ohne je zu
arbeiten und steuern zu zahlen die
gleichen sozialleistung halten wie die
die diese leistungen finanzieren müssen
dabei weist eine studie der uni
princeton auf basis dieser zahlen nach
das senkung von sozialleistungen zu
sinkender zuwanderung führt die hebung
zu steigender na dann sofort schluss mit
der forcierten so förderungen was für
absurde zustände dabei die horrenden
kosten unbegleiteter minderjähriger von
denen über 40 prozent tatsächlich
volljährig sind in aachen
tagesverpflegung für 13 euro pro asyl
bewerber hartz iv ihrer kriegen fünf
euro die monatskarte in hamburg für
migranten zu knapp 30 euro für normale
senioren über 60 euro das ist nichts
anderes als politik gegen die eigenen
bürger meine damen und herren und
zusätzlich zu alledem sind ja ausgaben
nötig für 180.000 neue kita-plätze den
2400 zusätzliche grundschulen 15.000
neue polizistenstellen 2000 neue
richterstellen für die asyl klagewelle
und die rente
amtspräsident sommer warnt viele der
flüchtlinge stehen heute in jobs
allerdings die allermeisten im
niedriglohnsektor
viele migranten würden später in
altersarmut abrutschen ach sieh an
da ist es ja gut zu wissen dass die
bundesbank dafür plädiert das
renteneintrittsalter weiter anzuheben
auf 69 jahre
dabei rutschten immer mehr unsere
händler die zeitlebens gearbeitet haben
den grundsicherung auf hartz-iv-niveau
alles weil diese regierung falsche
prioritäten setzt unbegrenzt geld für
migration aber der deutsche arbeitnehmer
zahlt jahrzehnte ein bekommt nichts
anständiges mal raus das ist pure
abzocke und das lassen die bürger sich
nicht länger gefallen und
die krankenversicherung schon nach 15
monaten halten migranten die vollen
leistungen die beiträge zahlt der bund
da steckt aber gerade mal die hälfte der
kosten
so entsteht trotz rekordeinnahmen in
2009 10 ein milliardendefizit nach einer
prognose im auftrag der
bertelsmann-stiftung droht in 20 jahren
ein minus von fast 50 milliarden euro
der bürger wir alle dürfen dann die
zeche zahle nicht weltoffen
das ist mit ansage und knappe acht
milliarden für die bekämpfung von
fluchtursachen komplett
rausgeschmissenes geld der
lebensstandard in afrika wird nie dem in
europa entsprechen können selbst
hängematte hier bringt mehr als arbeiten
dort aber von dem dort den überwiesenen
geld können sich noch mehr den
migrations tritt hierher leisten nutzen
0 schaden gigantisch und städte und
gemeinde bleiben auf den kosten sitzen
der bundeszuschuss steckt für hamburg
und sachsen nur ein viertel der echten
kosten die altschulden debatte bei den
kommunen soll auch deren totale
überlastung durch migrationskosten
verschleiern
und all das wird den bürgern komplett
ohne not aufgebürdet aufgebürdet schon
das instrument des selbst eintritts
zeigt ja dass man gar nicht zuständig
ist das ist raub von 50 milliarden pro
jahr und migrationsforscher sagen uns
man könnte damit nahe der heimatregion
hundertmal mehr migranten versorgung als
in europa die ganze humanitäre
verbrämung ist schlicht nonsens
wir fordern
die steuer und sozialabgaben der
zuwanderer den ausgaben gegenüber
stellen wir brauchen auskunft über
langzeit kosten in anbetracht des
tatsächlichen umfangs der
selbstversorgung der migranten über die
vervielfachung aller kosten durch
familiennachzug und nach kommen aber die
kosten
die trägt ja der staat er wird für diese
herausforderung geld in die hand nehmen
dumm nur für den bürger dass diese hand
die das geld in die hand nimmt vorher in
seiner tasche war meine damen und herren
diese politik deutschland mit migranten
zu fluten
den sozialstaat durch überdehnung zu
zerstören den rechtsstaat in den kollaps
zu treiben das ist gefährlicher
politischer extremismus
die wähler müssen handeln uns fehlt das
geld von der bildung über polizei und
justiz bis zur rente und
gesundheitswesen aber die selbst
berauschten gesinnungs fantasten die
verscherbeln diesen start um sich ihr
freundliches gesicht bescheinigen zu
lassen
wir brauchen endlich eine kohärente
darstellung und nicht dass vorher die
bürger bestohlen werden um schein
überschüsse zu deklarieren nein ich muss
ihnen sagen wenn du ein bäcker jeder
semmel
einen baum braucht man sollten
milliarden programme nicht verschleiert
werden zeit die bundesregierung in die
pflicht zu nehmen
gottfried choreo der innenpolitische
sprecher der fdp-fraktion hat hier die
debatte eröffnet zum antrag der afg zu
den finanziellen kosten in der
migrationspolitik
allerdings gibt es natürlich schon
angaben dazu zum beispiel in berichten
der bundesregierung und natürlich auch
in den haushaltsplänen mehr dazu werden
wir jetzt hören von eckhardt rehberg
erst der haushaltspolitische sprecher
der unions fraktion auf diese rede
vorbereitet habe habe ich genau das
erwartet und nichts anderes
und wenn sie wenn sie davon sprechen
dass die bürger betrogen werden dass die
bürger bluten müssen ausgenommen werden
müssen für die die aus not und elend aus
krieg zu uns kommen
sie wollen doch eine rechtsstaatspartei
sein sie hat noch den rechtsstaat immer
so hoch
am 18 juli 2012
das bundesverfassungsgericht recht
gesprochen ich zitiere mal die
kompletten drei leitsätze erstens die
höhe der geldleistung nach paragraf 3
des asylbewerberleistungsgesetzes ist
evident unzureichend weil sie seit 1993
nicht verändert worden sind zweitens
artikel 1 absatz 1 grundgesetz in
verbindung mit dem sozialstaatsprinzip
das artikel 20 absatz 1 grundgesetz
garantiert ein grundrecht auf
gewährleistung eines menschenwürdigen
existenzminimums artikel 1 absatz 1
grundgesetz begründet diesen anspruch
als menschenrecht das umfasst sowohl die
physische existenz des menschen als auch
die sicherung der möglichkeit zur pflege
zwischenmenschlicher beziehung ein
mindestmaß an teilhabe am
gesellschaftlichen kulturellen und
politischen leben
das grundrecht meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren stieg deutschen und
ausländischen staatsangehörigen diese
kinder bunte bild deutschland aufhalten
gleichermaßen zu
als gesetzt wie bei der feststellung des
menschenwürdigen existenzminimums die
besonderheiten bestimmter
personengruppen berücksichtigen will
darf er bei der konkreten ausgestaltung
existenz in der leistung nicht pauschal
nach dem aufenthaltsstatus
differenzieren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wenn sie herr choreo hier von
sozialleistungen sprechen ja deutschland
hat sehr hohe sozialleistungen für
diejenigen die nach artikel 16 absatz 2
zu uns kommen dann hat das im jahr 2012
das bundesverfassungsgericht
ausdrücklich festgelegt
und weil wir in der rechtsstaatspartei
sind als union und ich sprech glaube ich
hier für den gesamten deutschen
bundestag auf die fraktion dann haben
wir uns auch nach urteilen des
bundesverfassungsgerichts in karlsruhe
entsprechend auszurichten unsere politik
und unsere gesetzgebung
sie haben hier ein horror szenario an
die wand gebaut dass es menschen in
deutschland würden wir die jahre
übrigens richten um jahr 2015/16 sondern
über die jahre als flüchtlinge zu uns
gekommen sind schlechter geht zahlen
konfrontiert
es war das beste jahrzehnt das letzte
was deutschland erlebt hat für eine
beschäftigung von 45,3 millionen 45,3
millionen
die arbeitslosigkeit ist im schnitt bei
2,2 millionen in deutschland wurde noch
nie so viel investiert wie heute ja
ich könnte jetzt die unterrichtung der
bundesregierung nehmen worauf gelistet
ist und die länder berichten wo für
welches geld genommen worden ist ja und
wir haben das nicht nur für migranten
gemacht sondern der kita ausbaus
natürlich auch für die deutschen
der soziale wohnungsbau na klar das
zusätzliche geld aber der
herausforderung haben wir uns
schlichtweg gestellt belastung nicht
beim sozialbereich nur eins sagen ich
mache mir eine preisfrage
oder 2 welches bundesland hat die
niedrigste altersarmut in deutschland wo
ihr wissen sie dass und wie hoch sie zum
freistaat thüringen 1 prozent bei mir
zuhause 1,62 prozent beziehen
grundsicherung im alter und die renten
im osten sind in den letzten fünf jahren
um 22 prozent gestiegen ich kann ihnen
sagen weil zu uns menschen aus not
gekommen sind geht es keinen deutschen
schlechte den mist sie erzählt den hass
predigen dass es extremismus will kann
ich ihn zu diesem thema
wenn sie von willkommens-party sprechen
dann kann ich ihnen nur sagen vielleicht
begegnen sie sich war gedanklich dorthin
wo die menschen herkommen
begeben sie sich einfach mal dahin
gucken sich um was da los ist warum und
weshalb
und ich finde die acht milliarden die
wir ausweisen für flucht
ursachenbekämpfung entwicklungshilfe ist
noch ein bisschen größer ich finde es
sehr gut angelegtes geld
und das ist sehr gut angelegt verspielt
sie seien ihnen auch warum
wenn wir da nichts tun würden wir dort
not und elend noch viel größer wenn wir
dort nichts tun würde
im bereich klimaschutz der das thema
dort noch viel gravierender
und ich glaube dass gerade wir nehmen
sie die aktuelle situation in syrien in
libyen humanitäre hilfe warum haben sich
denn gerade im jahr 2015 fiel auf den
weg gemacht weil die täglichen
leistungen über die entsprechenden
hilfsorganisation runtergegangen sind
auch wenn ich es richtig im kopf ab 10
dollar im monat pro person 30 sind
normal
die zwischenfragen eigentlich erlaubt
keine zwischenfragen und die ursache war
mit dass sich die internationale
staatengemeinschaft dass dort die
menschen hungersnot in den lagern
gelitten haben und deswegen ist es ein
nicht nur ein zeichen von humanität dies
auch ein zeichen von klugheit das wir
das zu einer solchen situation im jahr
2015 16 nicht mehr kommen lassen werden
das hat nichts damit zu tun wie sie das
eben gepredigt haben dass wir menschen
in deutschland betrügen dass die
flüchtlinge auf kosten der deutschen
lehnen das ist alles quatsch was sie
erzählen ich finde wir sollten auch noch
jeder einzelne von uns einen humanitären
anspruch haben und diese humanitäre
anspruch und deswegen hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht auch davon
gesprochen ist ein menschenrecht konnte
ich kann ihnen sagen was ihn antritt was
ihren antrag betrifft da müssen sie
schon mal 10.800 kommunen fragen
die daten liegen nur darf oder bei den
finanzverwaltungen der länder oder bei
den ländern nicht kann ihn nur dringend
raten die unterlagen die mir zur
verfügung stehen
unterrichtung der bundesregierung
bericht der migrationsbeauftragten
bericht der bundesagentur für arbeit
das reicht mehr und herr kuriose letzte
bemerkung sie sprechen hier in ihrer
pressemitteilung groß die verwertbarkeit
der migranten ist verwertbar grad welche
begriffe menschen wie sie in
vorbereitete rede war ich positiv
überrascht wirklich positiv überrascht
wie viele aus kriegs und krisengebieten
mittlerweile in beschäftigung gekommen
sind es mir sehr sehr positive
entwickeln dass das schwierig wird
glaube ich wussten wir alle im herbst
2015 und mercury
ich glaube
dass sie wirklich mal sich ganz ruhig
überlegen sollten mit ihrer rede was das
für auswirkungen hat
im netz und letztendlich möglicherweise
auch auf der straße herzlichen dank sagt
eckhardt rehberg der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der unions fraktion auf ihn
folgt jetzt der innenpolitische sprecher
der liberalen constantin coole geht
gerade ans mikrofon
herr präsident meine damen und herren
die flüchtlingspolitik prägt die
politischen debatten in deutschland seit
dem jahr 2000 rund 15 und ja die
flüchtlingspolitik sie hat zu
administrativen und finanziellen
belastungen in deutschland geführt von
denen wir nicht wollen dass sie sich
wiederholen
erstes beispiel ist die personalpolitik
des bundesamtes für migration und
flüchtlinge da sind mitarbeiter vor die
tür gesetzt worden gut ausgebildet und
dann sind für die gleichen aufgaben neue
mitarbeiter eingestellt worden und am
ende hatte niemand mehr einen überblick
über die personalsituation im bundesamt
für migration und flüchtlinge
zweites beispiel sind die vorleistungen
in die viele kommunen gegangen sind da
sind ausgaben getätigt worden für die
unterbringung sind container angeschafft
worden die am ende nicht gebraucht
worden sind da sind ausgaben getätigt
worden auf die die kommunen lange warten
mussten bis sie erstattet worden sind
und auch das wollen wir dass es sich
meine damen und herren nicht wiederholt
und ein drittes beispiel einer
finanziellen situation die sich nicht
wiederholen soll ist die intransparente
asyl rücklage der bundesregierung auch
über dieses thema wollen wir sprechen
müssen wir sprechen auch das darf nicht
zum regelfall werden um all diese punkte
zu verhindern und in zukunft anders aus
zu gestalten brauchen wir eine geregelte
flüchtlings und migrationspolitik das
muss die antwort sein und das brauchen
wir und da gibt es hier im deutschen
bundestag übrigens auch eine große
mehrheit
es gibt allerdings meine damen und
herren eine fraktion im deutschen
bundestag der bobbahn interesse an einer
geregelten migrationspolitik und das ist
die fdp
denn die afg fraktion braucht eine
ungeregelte migrationspolitik wie die
luft zum atmen damit herr curio sich
hier hinstellen kann und seine texte
vorlesen kann braucht die afg eine
ungeregelte migrationspolitik es gab ja
kaum ein thema was sie angesprochen
haben was nicht mit dem thema migration
zu tun haben soll sie haben glaube ich
bildung erwähnt rente wohnen verkehr der
mann nichts dabei was nach ihrer
auffassung was nach dem was sie hier
vortragen haben nicht die schuld von
ausländern sein soll es doch absurd wie
das hier in verbindung miteinander
gesetzt worden ist und deswegen hat das
mit diesem thema nichts zu tun und
deswegen werden wir hier mit einer
großen mehr im deutschen bundestag ihnen
diese strategie nicht durchgehen lassen
wenn ich gegen was sagen zu dem was
sagen deutschland wird sich verändern
deutschland wird sich verändern egal ob
flüchtlinge kommen oder nicht
deutschland wird anders aussehen in
vielen jahren unabhängig davon ob die
migrationspolitik auf die eine oder auf
die andere art und weise gestaltet wird
ja wir brauchen eine andere
migrationspolitik um eine eskalation
beim bundesamt für migration und
flüchtlinge zu verhindern
wir brauchen eine andere
flüchtlingspolitik um die kommunen zu
entlasten und wir wollen keine erneute
asyl rücklage aber am demografischen
wandel in deutschland und all seinen
implikationen für das thema pflege für
das thema wohnen da endet das thema
flüchtlinge doch überhaupt nichts am
thema digitalisierung mit all seinen
implikationen mit der veränderung der
arbeitswelt mit der veränderung des
lernens daran ändert das thema ausländer
das thema integration überhaupt nicht
und die sie versuchen alle veränderungen
in der gesellschaft zurückzuführen auf
das thema migration da muss den menschen
früher oder später erkennbar werden das
ist eine politische strategie der hier
dahinter steht und diese politische
strategie die wird möglicherweise von
der mehrheit des deutschen bundestages
abgelehnt vielen dank
und dann den kohle war das
innenpolitischer sprecher der fdp
auf ihn folgt hier zeige lind er ist für
die sozialdemokraten sprecher führt
demokratie
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe
mir ja auch die schmerzhafte tätigkeit
zugemutet mir die pressekonferenz der
afg zur vorstellung dieses antrages
anzuschauen
dort trugen sie herr curio ihr
manuskript mit scheinbar nüchternheit
vor
heute haben sie die agro version
präsentiert ich stelle aber fest dass
dieser goebbels verschnitt schlecht war
es tut mir leid das ist leider nicht
hinreichend gewesen für ein kompliment
auf einem plakat des rasse amtes der
nsdap aus dem jahr 1938 zu finden als
quelle im deutschen historischen museum
findet sich passend zu einer
entsprechenden abbildung folgende
aufschrift ich zitiere 60.000 reichsmark
kostet dieser ab kranke die
volksgemeinschaft auf lebenszeit zweiter
satz ich zitiere volksgenossen das ist
auch dein geld für solche anträge
gestellt wie die fdp-fraktion für solche
reden hält weiß in welcher tradition er
sich einreiht nämlich um diese tradition
für uns
demokratische fraktion im parlament
bemisst sich die würde des menschen
danach dass er ist egal woher kommt der
wert des menschen ist begründet in eben
dieser würde für die afg fraktion
bemisst sich offensichtlich der wert des
menschen sofern der
migrationshintergrund hat geflüchtet ist
oder aus anderen gründen hergekommen ist
an den kosten die er verursacht und an
seiner nützlichkeit und verwertbarkeit
das ist der fundamentale unterschied von
dem wir sprechen
des weiteren stelle ich fest
der applaus war durchaus berechtigt im
übrigen stelle ich fest dass sie ihnen
am antrag in einem scheinbar klugen
manöver davon schreiben dass die ihnen
die aus sogenannten humanitären gründen
kommen würden nur noch von ihnen
migranten genannt werden das ist im
sinne der transparenz diese beanspruchen
sehr transparent das ist nämlich
durchschaubar dämlich indem sie einfach
flüchtlinge zu migranten um stempel
wollen und noch eine dritte
eigentümlichkeit finde ich in ihrem
antragspaket ich erinnere mich doch ich
habe selbst damals gesprochen dass sie
zum beispiel im antrag grenzkontrollen
märz 2018 grosz forderte man solle
vielmehr investieren in die
fluchtursachen und die flut ursachen
bekämpfen
und jetzt skandalisieren sie die kosten
für fluchtursachen bekämpfen lesen wir
wenigstens ihre eigenen anträge und
nicht solche dummheiten und logischen
inkonsistenzen zu produzieren all das
wer genug grund diesen antrag in den
orkus des vergessens zu verdammt dann
aber komm ich letztlich doch zum anderen
schluss ich habe nämlich die zahlen
gesehen ich sah dass mittlerweile von
den letzten jahren gekommenen aus den
haupt asyl ländern 431.000 arbeit sind
zahlen von 2009 10 357.000 davon
sozialversicherungspflichtig deutlich
über 33 mittlerweile in arbeit das ist
weit mehr als wir noch vor jahren
erwartet haben und ich stelle fest
in vielen projekten wie geflüchtete hoch
engagiert sind um deutschland etwas
zurückzugeben wie sie sagen
deshalb ist manch muss jetzt dass ich
ihnen dankbar bin für den antrag und die
aufforderung dass wir mal eine
aufstellung machen
transparenz und beginnen wir mit der
aufstellung und da sicher mit dem antrag
sämtliche behörden auf landes bundes und
kommunaler ebene für monate beschäftigen
werden übertrage ich ihnen die aufgabe
weil sie sich ein bereich
rechtsextremismus und migration so gut
auskennt diese aufstellung zu machen und
was beinhaltet diese aufstellung
sie beinhaltet sämtliche kosten die
durch rechtsextreme täter durch
verletzung durch traumata bei opfern von
rechtsextremismus und rechtspopulismus
in diesem land verursacht worden
sie umfasst sämtliche kosten die
rechtspopulistische abgeordnete mit
ihren angehörigen und ihre mitarbeiter
in sämtlichen deutschen parlamenten den
deutschen staat verursachen sie
beinhaltet diese aufstellung alles was
migranten in diesem land seit
gründung der bundesrepublik als das
dabei als gastarbeiter als geflüchtete
erarbeitet haben ich erwarte von ihnen
auch sauber aufgeschlüsselt in dieser
aufstellung dass sie sämtliche
leistungen von ausländern ausländern in
deutschen krankenhäusern in
pflegeeinrichtungen auf 10 nämlich da
waren es wird nach medien und wird man
lesen südkoreanern und viele andere aus
unterschiedlichen ländern die sich
gekümmert haben die menschen auf deutsch
gesagt deutschen den hintern abgewischt
haben und dies auch machen werden selbst
wenn da rechtspopulist und
rechtsextremen krankenhaus in der
pflegeeinrichtung wegen und ich erwarte
von ihnen dass sie genau auflisten was
unseren kosten entsteht für ausbau der
sicherheitsapparate für stärken des
verfassungsschutzes alles nur verursacht
wegen ihren und dieser gesinnung die sie
in diesem land willkommen zum schluss
gelungen
abschließend bin ich zutiefst überzeugt
dass wir wenn ihr diese rechnung
aufmachen
die rechnung der leistung von
migrantinnen und migranten in diesem
land der opportunitätskosten aber des
rassismus den sie verursachen wird das
ergebnis ein ganz eindeutiges sagen und
jetzt wird für die demokratinnen und
demokraten in diesem haus sprechen die
würde des menschen in seinem dasein
betrachten und nicht in seinem
migrationshintergrund um die nicht
verwerten für seine kosten vielen dank
haye gewinnen hat hier noch mal
vorgeschlagen dann kosten nutzen
rechnungen wenn man sich schon auf macht
in beide richtungen aufzumachen das
dürfte allerdings schwierig sein das
umzusetzen nächste rednerin jetzt ist
gesine lötzsch haushaltspolitische
sprecherin der linksfraktion fordern
mehr transparenz von der bundesregierung
wir wollen endlich konkrete angaben zur
steuerhinterziehung der vermögen
wir wollen wissen wie es um die maßlose
verschwendung bei der bundeswehr
bestellt ist und wir wollen auskunft
darüber
wie der verfassungsschutz illegal geld
dafür ausgegeben hat
rechtsterroristische truppen zu
unterstützen
da stoßen wir auf eine mauer des
schweigens das nehmen wir nicht hin mein
land und ich glaube die öffentlichkeit
sollte wissen was die bundesregierung
nun selbst zu den sogenannten
flüchtlings kosten rechnet die
weltweiten auslandseinsätze der
bundeswehr mit personalausgaben
verwaltungsausgaben erhaltung von mehr
material militärische beschaffungen wie
absurd ist das denn
selbst der titel trennungsgeld
fahrtkostenzuschüsse sowie umzugskosten
vergütungen fließt in die berechnung der
sogenannten flüchtlings kosten mit ein
das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen sagt
man bei uns in berlin
und ich finde es wirklich absurd und da
denkt man nämlich die hetze und den hass
der menschen auf die geflüchteten und
das darf nicht sein damit er und ich
sage auch ganz deutlich die bundeswehr
bekämpft in afghanistan keine
fluchtursachen ist mit dafür
verantwortlich dass menschen aus ganz
tann nach deutschland flüchten und
deshalb fordern wir den sofortigen
rückzug der bundeswehr aus afghanistan
diese sorgen akten von der
bundesregierung selbst beschrieben und
flüchtlings kosten sind also drei
milliarden euro für verdeckte
kriegsführung eingeplant und das ist der
größte posten unter den öffentlich so
genannten flüchtlings kosten und ich
finde kosten für auslandseinsätze dürfen
da nicht eingerechnet werden das erhitzt
die bevölkerung in unserem land und
leben stellen ganz entgegen
und ich kann nur sagen wenn die
antragstellende fraktion die flüchtlings
kosten drastisch senken will dann muss
im bundestag nur konsequent gegen jeden
kriegseinsatz der bundeswehr stimmt das
wäre der richtige weg meine damen und
herren
das problem ist nur nicht für das noch
einmal ganz deutlich sagen dass die
bundesregierung selbst völlig überhöhte
flüchtlings kosten veröffentlicht das
ist ein spiel mit dem feuer denn
menschen mit geringem einkommen fragen
sich warum die bundesregierung kein geld
für armutsfeste renten für
alleinerziehende mütter und für
preiswerte wohnung bereitstellt aber
geld für geflüchtete und darum fordern
wir als linke ehrliche zahlen denn mit
den manipulierten zahlen wird die
konkurrenz unter den armen menschen
verstärkt die menschen sollen nicht
sehen dass die bundesregierung die
vermögenden in unserem land bevorzugt
wir sagen mit diesen falschen zahlen wo
der soziale friede zerstört und die
rechtsextreme wie wir das grab gesehen
und gehört haben gestärkt und dem muss
ein ende gesetzt werden
vielen dank vielen dank frau conny lösch
als nächste
trainerin hat die kollegin luise
amtsberg und 90 die grünen müssen sie
ist die flüchtlingspolitische sprecherin
ihrer fraktion kollegen als wenn es den
tatsächlich ums geld ging als wenn die
intention dieses antrages tatsächlich
von der sorge um die richtige verwendung
von steuergeldern getragen wird
natürlich nicht ja nein infoma fd geht
es nicht ums geld die antrag hat eine
politische intention
sie wollen dafür hätten sie keine acht
seiten gebraucht doch eigentlich nur
sagen wir wollen keine zuwanderung wir
wollen keine flüchtlinge aufnehmen in
diesem land das kostenargument ist
vorgeschoben
in dem antrag nennt die updates und her
selbst die zahlen nach denen sie fragt
sie zitieren selbst die quellen wo
drinsteht was der bund zahlt auch die
landeshaushalte weisen die unmittelbaren
kosten aus sie brauchen eigentlich nur
nachlesen
das würde aber ihre erzählungen das muss
man erwähnen der stadt vertuscht doch
hier irgendwas die bundesregierung die
bilder gar nicht dass der bürger die
echten zahlen kennt dazu würde das
natürlich nicht passen und im übrigen
wir kennen diese methode die es nicht
neu das hat alles beide schon 2018 in
bezug auf den eu haushalt versucht aber
das nur am rande
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen worum es
in dem antrag eigentlich geht sind die
von der ard so getauften indirekten
kosten der migrationspolitik ja die neue
erzählung der afg die indirekten kosten
darunter sollen zb auch die kosten für
die abfallwirtschaft fallen im ernst
jetzt wollen sie künftig dann auch dass
die kosten für die sanierung
öffentlicher gebäude in die auch
geflüchtete gehen anteilig an rechnen
oder die sanierung von gehwegen weil
auch diese von geflüchteten menschen
benutzt werden es kam und ihr ernst sein
als ich werde noch konkreter man sich
kein song als indirekte kosten führt die
ard übrigens auch projekte an die die
akzeptanz der migration anhöhen sollen
also hier fällt mir ganz konkreten wir
reden da über kosten über finanzen eine
einsparmöglichkeit ein nämlich wenn sie
aufhören würden den ganzen tag stimmung
gegen geflüchtete menschen zu machen
kosten für demokratie projekte sind
nämlich kosten die sie mit ihrer politik
doch nun die höhe treiben und das ist
eigentlich mit den kosten die durch
forderungen in ihrem antrag entstehen
die hunderte von stellen und tausenden
arbeitsstunden zur erhebung von daten
die zum teil gar nicht messbar sind
wissen sie keiner hält sie davon ab
inhaltlich zu kritisieren wenn sie
finden dass eine asylpolitik geld falsch
ausgegeben wird oder falsche prioritäten
gesetzt werden
wir machen das auch janker zentren zum
beispiel zu wenig sprachkurse oder das
chancen verspielt werden arbeits verbote
fehlender spurwechsel oder wenn kosten
entstehen die nicht notwendig sind zum
beispiel bei den verwaltungsgerichten
aufgrund schlechter bank bescheide meine
liste ist lang aber die mühe machen sie
sich gar nicht denn sie kritisieren und
das ist das wichtige sie kritisieren
einen politischen grundsatz die aufnahme
von geflüchteten lehnen sie kategorisch
ab historische verantwortung in diesem
land hin oder her
sie leben das ab und mit diesem antrag
versuchen sie entlang von kosten zu
argumentieren und das zu verbessern und
ich finde eigentlich aber gar nicht so
schlecht dass über kosten reden ja weil
es die möglichkeit gibt zu ihrer politik
zwei dinge zu sagen
das eine ist keine flüchtlings und
integrationspolitik ist teurer als die
dastehen
und das zweite ist es ist offensichtlich
dass sie für bestimmte probleme in
dieser gesellschaft überhaupt keine
antwort haben
rechnen sie den menschen doch mal vor
was passiert wenn ihre forderungen nach
geschlossenen deutschen grenzen
wirklichkeit wird wenn wir nicht mehr
teil des eu binnenmarktes sind was das
wirtschaftlich bedeutet für unser land
wenn es nach ihnen ginge wären doch
diese sogenannten indirekten kosten noch
viel viel höher
sie sind es doch die geflüchtete jede
gesellschaftliche beteiligung und
integration versagen diesen menschen in
unserem land die chance versagen die
damit einhergehen dem restriktionen wie
arbeits verbote nicht weit genug gehen
denen die aufwendung für sprachkurse zu
hoch sind sie sind es die geflüchteten
menschen überhaupt absprechen echte
gründe zu haben hier zu sein
das wird in ihrem antrag durch total
klar und die größte unverschämtheit aber
das ist ja wirklich das ausbleiben
sämtliche antworten auf drängende fragen
haben sie meckern und sie reden dieses
land schlecht das tun sie den ganzen tag
und ich weiß dass die von der afg meine
generation und jünger nicht wirklich
interessiert das habe ich schon gelernt
deshalb helfen jetzt echt gern mal auf
die sprünge die direkten auswirkungen
ihrer isolationistischen politiker würde
doch vor allem die jüngeren diesen
ländern zu spüren bekommt und deshalb
und deshalb kamen sie verdammt noch mal
den hintern in der hose dann auch aus zu
buchstabieren was das bedeutet was die
antworten sind sie leben zu wanderungen
ab was ist denn ihre antwort auf den
demografischen wandel auf die
fortschreitende überalterung unserer
gesellschaft auf den mangel an fach- und
hilfskräfte näher sorry aber das ist
genau das was die hören menschen in
diesem land interessieren denn für sie
ist es existenziell
und es gibt ja
sie zielen ja auch in ihrem gesamten
antrag das finde ich auch interessant ja
sehr auf ballungsräume dass er komplett
fokussiert auf die städte und die
wachsenden steht sie vergessen den
ländlichen raum komplett
es gibt gegenden in deutschland den geht
es nicht gut da gibt es nicht nur keine
flüchtlinge sondern auch alle anderen
gerade die jungen gerade die jungen
frauen ziehen dort weg geschäfte
schließen die soziale infrastruktur geht
verloren und zurück bleibt große
frustration
ich verstehe dass zuwanderung ist in
diesen gebieten keine frage des wollens
sondern sie ist eine notwendigkeit und
sie ist eine chance und gute politik die
alle mit denkt würde das auch erkennen
mal abseits davon und damit endlich dann
auch die antrag der trifft ja nur so
fanta verwertungslogik und ich finde es
ist ehrlich gesagt nicht in geld
aufzuwiegen menschen vor dem tod im
krieg zu retten aber das nur als
abschließender impuls vielleicht kommt
er an vielen landsberg wies der für die
cdu/csu-fraktion kollegen alexander tun
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrter herr präsident werde
kolleginnen kollegen um was geht es der
fdp nach ausnehmen
in zahlen um angebliche transparenz und
in der tat geht es ihnen doch eigentlich
nur darum den keine in unserer
gesellschaft noch ein bisschen tiefer
hinein zu droppen die einen die inländer
gegen die ausländer auszuspielen damit
ihr politisches spiel zu betreiben in
der tat sie brauchen derartige anträge
und sie brauchen diese spaltung in der
gesellschaft für ihr politik modell der
kollegen inzwischen fragen sich die
fraktionen jetzt lassen sie mich erstmal
ein bisschen ausführen und dann kümmern
da gerne vielleicht noch zum späteren
zeitpunkt drauf
zurück kommen der antrag spricht
ausschließlich von lasten der migration
aber nicht vom möglichen nutzen den die
migration durchaus auch hat und sie
schreiben nicht nur von der
flüchtlingspolitik der kosten der
flüchtlingspolitik sondern sie schreiben
ausdrücklich von den finanziellen lasten
der migrationspolitik
das ist aber deutlich mehr als nur asyl
und flucht wie wir es in den letzten
jahren erlebt haben und deswegen sollten
wir da etwas differenzierter an die
sache herangehen und ohne scheuklappen
diese ganz offensichtlich aussitzen
haben migration ist nämlich in aller
erster linie arbeitsmigration und die
haben wir in den 70er jahren mit dem
sogenannten gastarbeitern hier von uns
aus von deutschland aus initiiert und in
den letzten jahren sind allein über 2,7
millionen eu ausländer nach deutschland
gekommen und lagen hier mit ihrer arbeit
zur sicherung und stärkung unseres
wirtschaftsstandortes bei und egal wo
wir uns momentan bewegen welcher branche
auch immer gehören vom fachkräfte
und deswegen haben wir ja auch ein fakt
der einwanderungsgesetze letztes jahr
beschlossen auch das trägt dann zu
nutzen zur stärkung unserer wirtschaft
bei denn nur dadurch können wir wenn wir
auch entsprechende fachkräfte in
deutschland haben wenn wir eine gewisse
arbeitsmigration haben auch im nicht
ganz hoch qualifizierten bereich soll in
reinen fachbereich dann können wir den
wohlstand für zukünftige generationen
sichern da kommen dann die menschen die
wir brauchen und nicht durch die
menschen die uns brauchen als wir
sollten da durchaus differenzierter
traut sind dann haben sie natürlich ihr
klientel im blick wo sie mit ihrem
antrag auch die vorurteile
wo sie sagen den deutschen etwas
genommen weil sehr viele flüchtlinge
gekommen sind das ist aber ein
durchschaubares spiel ja natürlich hat
dies auch lasten zufolge aber keineswegs
nur ausschließliche lasten durch die
flüchtlinge die kommen schutz berechtigt
oder nicht so der integrationskurse
sprachkurse und vieles andere wird auch
für teilnehmer aus den eu staaten
angeboten ganz genauso auch für reguläre
arbeiten kann oder aber auch etwa
spätaussiedler und insofern lässt es
sich nicht eins zu eins auf rechnen und
dann haben wir diejenigen die zu uns
kommen weil sie verfolgt sind weil sie
aus einem kriegsland kommen weil sie
brauchen schutz suchen
und da kann man glaube ich nicht alles
in euro und cent ausrechnen nicht
überall eine bilanz ziehen und den
volkswirtschaftlichen nutzen
herausrechnen sondern da ist dann
einfach eins auch gefragt was ihr
offensichtlich komplett abgeht und das
ist humanität
ich glaube wir übrigen fraktionen hier
im parlament haben die humanität
durchaus auch in unterschiedlichen
ausprägungen was den detailfragen
anbelangt aber wir sind uns im grundsatz
eigentlich dass wir denjenigen die
schutz brauchen diesen auch gewähren ja
und auch dann wenn er für uns für
unseren staat lassen wir dafür unsere
kosten hat verlässlich angesprochen
worden
viele derer die in den letzten jahren
gekommen sind tragen inzwischen durch
ihre arbeit auch zum
volkswirtschaftlichen nutzen bei 40.000
junge menschen aus den asyl
hauptherkunftsländern machen eine
ausbildung
rund 360.000 schutzberechtigte gehen
einer sozialversicherungspflichtigen
arbeit nach
das ist mehr als wir erwartet haben aber
ich sage auch ganz offen noch nicht so
viel dass wir uns ausruhen kissen legen
können
hier gibt es noch knapp 600.000 menschen
die erwerbsfähig sind die anerkannt sind
als flüchtling aber im sgb 2 system
leben und da müssen wir durchaus mehr
machen diese müssen wir motivieren
diesen müssen wir besser an die arbeit
heranführen etwa indem wir
verpflichtende arbeitseinheiten ein
stück weit ein funkelnder für diesen
personenkreis wie es beispielsweise in
ähnlicher form auch schon in schweden
und anderswo gemacht wird als insofern
würde ich mir von ihnen konstruktive
vorschläge wünschst du nicht so eine
debatte die sich hier heute vom zaun
brechen einfach nur um den zwiespalt in
unserer gesellschaft noch mehr zu führen
konstruktive vorschläge sind von ihnen
nicht zu erwarten alles was sie hier
schreiben und wir an tragen aber auch
ausgeführt haben ohne weiteren
erkenntnis wird und deswegen werden
genannt auch abwägen
allerdings wird der antrag erst einmal
überwiesen in die entsprechenden
ausschüsse bevor der bundestag darüber
abstimmt es ist allerdings noch nicht
klar in welchen ausschuss das
federführend überwiesen wird jetzt geht
aber erst einmal die debatte weiter
christoph meyer vom haushaltsausschuss
für die fdp fraktion sehr schnell fest
dass er von fehlern falschdarstellungen
falschen behauptung nur so trieft und
strotzt ich möchte das ja curio nur an
einem einzigen beispiel festmachen sie
sind abgeordnete aus berlin sind noch
nicht mal in der lage in diesen antrag
reinzuschreiben dass der viel
diskutierte mieten deckel der von rot
rot grünen senat eingeführt werden soll
nicht zum ersten er
20 20 in kraft getreten ist sondern erst
später in kraft tritt und ich glaube das
ist sehr bezeichnend dafür wenn man sich
die einzelnen themenfelder die kollegen
ja schon angesprochen hat anguckt wird
man wenn man fachleute aus den
jeweiligen fachgebieten hier im haus
befragt sehr schnell in jedem einzelnen
thema fehler und falschdarstellungen
identifizieren und deswegen ist es so
wurden bereits häufiger gesagt das
einzige ziel von ihnen ist hier weiter
angst zu schüren und das werden sie
nicht durchgehen lassen
ich bin herrn rebak sehr dankbar dafür
dass er sehr deutlich formuliert hat
dass zum einen die zahlen vorliegen und
zum anderen was in der tat sie hier in
diesem antrag bezwecken
wenn man sich die diktion anguckt hart
arbeitende deutsche bürger keine gegen
rechnungen von migrations erfolgen
überall da wo sie selbst nicht genau
wissen wie ihre behauptungen mit zahlen
unterlegt werden kommen sie mit
gutachter aufträgen her wo sie also
irgendwie ein zahlenwerk definieren
wollen und das ist das haben ja sehr
viel innenpolitiker hier gesprochen vor
ein haushälter denn doch ein bisschen
viel wir haben schon das gefühl dass wir
an der einwohner stelle ein bisschen
mehr transparenz benötigen im zahlenwerk
aber sicherlich nicht so wir müssen
darüber reden
dass der kontrollverlust der im jahr
2015 hier uns alle bewegt hat so nicht
mehr stattfindet aber das bedeutet nicht
dass wir im jahr 2020 so ein antrag auch
nur ernsthaft beraten können oder das
ergebnis der mehrwert für uns alle
gleich null ist und deswegen werden wir
diesen antrag ablehnen schild wesentlich
wichtiger wäre es wenn wir uns in der
tat über so etwas wie die flüchtlings
reserve oder rücklage unterhalten würden
darüber reden würden dass hier wieder
eine schatztruhe von rot schwarz oder
schwarz rot im nächsten jahr doch wieder
praller gefüllt ist als ursprünglich
gedacht was damit gemacht werden soll
das wäre konstruktive arbeit aber dazu
sind sie ja offensichtlich in der lage
deswegen werden wir diesen antrag
ablehnen nächster redner in dieser
debatte ist lars castellucci er ist für
die sozialdemokraten sprecher für
migration und integration
vielen dank herr präsident meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen migration
erstmal ein ziemlich normaler vorgang
und das kann man an dem antrag der afc
auch erkennen denn er ist ein gebracht
unter anderem von peter bis bonn geboren
in der tschechoslowakei und frau cota
und hanns frohnmeyer geboren in rumänien
und ja das kostet etwas denn zum
beispiel kostet es uns jetzt hier
lebenszeit für die immer gleichen
absurden und menschenverachtenden
anträge diesem jahr
und dann gibt es ja noch andere leute
die profile und herren - und jetzt
zuletzt auch herrn herrmann die sind
weiter gewandert
sie können also nicht mal
sekundärinfektionen bei ihnen aufhalten
und es zeigt ja menschen suchen menschen
suchen ein besseres leben und der erste
schritt zu einem besseren leben ist ein
leben ohne die afd
jetzt kommen wir zur sache und zum ernst
der sache und dafür möchte ich sagen der
ernst kommt in einer zahl zum ausdruck
1616 ist in europa die durchschnittliche
zahl geburtenrate der frauen
das zeigt wir sind in ganz europa
angewiesen auf einwanderung wenn unser
kontinent einfach vor sich hin schrumpft
einfach vor sich hin altert werden wir
unseren wohlstand nicht halten können
dann ist die pflege dann sind die
sozialversicherung der künftigen
generation nicht gesichert deutschland
und europa braucht einwanderung das ist
die wahrheit
und es kommt einzig und allein darauf an
dass wir sie gerecht und gut gestalten
und herr kurios sie betreiben hier nicht
nur hetze sondern sie verbreiten hier
auch noch die unwahrheit
denn das hamburger modell ist gerade
vorbildlich denn hier werden nicht
menschen mit geringem einkommen in
hamburg und geflüchtete gegeneinander
gestellt sondern alle haben den gleichen
anspruch auf mobilität mit dem
unterschied dass die geflüchteten das
von ihrem taschengeld zwangsweise
abgezogen bekommen ich halte das für ein
gutes modell in hamburg und sie sollten
sich besser informieren bevor sie hier
falsch behauptungen verbreiten
wir sind auf migrationen angewiesen aber
die flüchtlinge könnte man sagen da bin
ich sehr dankbar dass das von meinen
vorrednern schon herausgearbeitet worden
des erstens ich bin so erzogen
wenn jemand hilfe braucht und du kannst
helfen
dann hilft und ich bin stolz und froh
dass unser land das helfen kann in den
letzten jahren viel geholfen hat und das
auch noch weiter tun dort und ich bin
dankbar der bevölkerung dies unterstützt
und gleichzeitig haben wir die erfolge
das von den menschen die zu uns gekommen
sind schon 435.000 auf dem arbeitsmarkt
erfolgreich sein können
zu fast 90% in
sozialversicherungspflichtiger
beschäftigung und das zeigt die
geschichten können mit krieg mitleid
beginnen weil wir haben es als chance
miteinander dass wir zum besseren
gestalten können das ist unser anspruch
daran arbeiten wir und dafür bitte ich
auch das ganze haus und unterstützung
vielen dank sind die finanziellen kosten
der migrationspolitik umfassend
offengelegt darüber diskutiert der
bundestag beziehungsweise kann man
überhaupt die kosten einer person die in
deutschland schutz sucht offenlegen und
beziffern der politik spricht jetzt für
die linksfraktion die über die
sogenannte finanziellen lasten der
migrationspolitik ist wie alle anderen
anträge papierkorb anträge der afg
fachlich falsch und rein
rechtspopulistische hetze die wir uns
hier immer wieder anhören müssen
sie gehen mit ihrer history falsche
bilder und wollen im grunde genommen den
leuten nur angst machen
ich selber betreuen zahlreiche
einzelfälle
eine frau hat sich vor kurzem bei mir
gemeldet die wir seit längerer zeit
betreuen
maria
kommt aus syrien hat einen großen teil
ihrer familie während des krieges
verloren
marian ist eine von denen die fliehen
musste und die sie hier jetzt als
finanzielle last abstempeln und es ist
ein hohn auf maria und auf ihre
verstorbene familie und auf alle
menschen die aus kriegsgebieten fliehen
dass sie so hier über sie herziehen das
ist schlichtweg eine schande
mariam steht kurz davor die studium zu
beenden und wird anschließend anfangen
hier zu arbeiten und im gegensatz zu der
afg ist hier eine bereicherung für
unsere gesellschaft hier als
linksfraktion stehen an der seite derer
die aus kriegsgebieten fliehen und auch
unterstützung und hilfe brauchen
sie sprechen von einer verschleierung
der kosten und fordern eine offenlegung
der daten
die kosten sind weitestgehend zugänglich
wie auch hier erklärt worden ist
deutschland hat die aufnahme und
versorgung von flüchtlingen mit einer
schwarzen null im haushalt bewältigt die
migrantische bewerten bevölkerung hier
in deutschland arbeitet und leistet
ihren beitrag zur finanzierung des
steuer und rentensystems und wenn sie
von harter arbeit sprechen in ihrem
antrag dann sind es in erster linie
flüchtlinge und migranten die im
niedriglohnsektor unter schwierigsten
bedingungen arbeiten
wer arbeitet
im baugewerbe in der gastronomie oder
auch im reinigungsgewerbe hier in
deutschland und selbst hier den
bundestag das können sie sich mal auch
morgens hier anschauen
es ist genau dieser facebook politischer
diskurs der hier von ihm geführt wird
der mitverantwortlich ist für die
restriktionen im bereich asyl und
migrationspolitik der bundesregierung
der letzten jahre und das muss sich
ändern wenn man von kosten spricht darf
man auf die kosten der abschreckung
nicht vergessen die abschreckungspolitik
der bundesregierung kommt den
steuerzahler teuer zu stehen
die unterbringung in ein paar zentren
und anderen lagern kostet beispielsweise
um ein vielfaches mehr als eine
dezentrale und integrationsfördernde
unterbringung in wohnungen
meine damen und herren wenn wir wirklich
über verschleierung von kasten sprechen
da müssen wir uns auch über die afg
sprechen ihre parteispitze hat vor
wenigen tagen ein gerichtsverfahren
verloren bei dem es um ihre illegalen
parteispenden geht sie stellen sich hier
das café fordern offenlegung und
gleichzeitig weiß ihre eigene
parteispitze nicht wo plötzlich bei
herrn wollten zum beispiel 90.000 euro
herkommen und erzählen es gab keine
professionelle organisation damals
sie können den anderen menschen nichts
nicht mal den familiennachzug zu ihren
angehörigen und wollen rechtfertigen
dass in nebenlagen freundschafts
verdienste von 90.000 euro okay sind sie
sind schlichtweg verlogen und einfachen
menschen zeitlich viel ein
als nächster redner das wort situation
der kollege florian außen florian oßner
sitzt im haushaltsausschuss des
bundestags
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
gerade eben erst das jahr begonnen und
schon fühlt man sich irgendwie wieder an
den film erinnert und täglich grüßt das
murmeltier
denn wir debattieren wieder einmal
wieder einmal einen offensichtlichen
schaufenster antrag der fdp fraktion zur
flüchtlingspolitik der augenscheinliche
zweck dieses antrages ist es den
falschen anschein zu erwecken
die bundesregierung könnte die nicht mit
dem geld umgehen
dabei hat der bund im fünften jahr in
folge erhebliche haushaltsüberschüsse zu
verzeichnen
in 2009 10 sogar eine rekord summe von
13 5 milliarden euro statt ständigen
nörgeln der afg verdient dass je mehr
das lob für dies für das
verantwortungsvolle handeln unsere
haushälter und finanzpolitiker der
großen koalition
sie schreiben in einem einleitenden satz
die direkten und indirekten kosten der
sogenannten flüchtlings migration für
den deutschen steuerzahler sind bis
heute nicht umfassend dargestellt
auch da muss man sagen das ist deshalb
schon falsch weil sich die länder die
kosten ihrer kommune und ihre eigenen
kosten vom bund erstatten lassen
belasten eben nicht unsere kommunen im
stich bei diesem doch oft auch
schwierigen aufgaben
zu diesem zwecke erstellt aber das
bundesfinanzministerium einen jährlichen
flüchtlings kosten bericht der auf jedem
mehr im bundestag als drucksaal zugeht
im bericht benennt das ministerium dabei
auf die flüchtlings kosten die direkt
beim bund entstehen insbesondere und es
wird interessant und kostenblock flucht
ursachenbekämpfung sind auch titel des
bundesministeriums für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit eine entwicklung
enthalten
meine vorredner sind dabei schon darauf
eingegangen dass läuft das gerade immer
gefordert hat die ganz unabhängig von
flüchtlingen in deutschland anfallen
würden sofern deutschland ist als
wichtig erachte sich der weltweiten
armut probleme anzunehmen
aus meiner sicht ein absolut wichtiger
punkt bundesminister gerd müller macht
hier eine hervorragende arbeit
wir haben als cdu csu fraktion zusammen
mit unserem koalitionspartner in den
letzten jahren viel dafür getan die
fluchtgründe zu bekämpfen erfolg ist
messbar
die zahl der schutz suchen ist
hierzulande kontinuierlich
zurückgegangen kamen noch 2015 glaube
890.000 asylsuchende nach deutschland
sank die zahl im jahr 216 auf 280.000
und im letzten im vergangenen jahr auf
111.000 damit liegt die zahl der
asylanträge tor auf dem niveau von 2014
die im jahr vor ausbruch der
flüchtlingskrise dass es im bislicher
auf zahlreiche maßnahmen des pakets 1
zurückzuführen
die asylverfahren wurden beschleunigt
allen voran von sachen geldleistungen
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen abstimmungen
werden grundsätzlich nicht mehr
angekündigt die strafbarkeit von
schleusern wurde verschärft und die
änderungen im baurecht erleichtern die
unterbringung der asylbewerber und es
geht auch weiterhin das ipad 2 zu wurden
der familiennachzug für bestimmte
gruppen eingeschränkt es wurden
aufnahmezentren für die verfahren zu
beschleunigen für migranten ohne
bleibeperspektive aufgebaut
leistungsbezug gibt es nur mehr an
zuweisung ort und letzter punkt
abschiebe hinterlässt als gewöhnlichen
gesundheitlichen gründen wurde minimiert
um nur wenige beispiele zu nennen sie
sehen das zeigt die unionsgeführte
bundesregierung hat alles dazu getan
die mehrfach zitierte flüchtlingskrise
von vor fünf jahren erfolgreich in den
griff zu bekommen
die globale flüchtlingsproblematik wird
uns jedoch auch im jahr 2020 noch
intensiv beschäftigen nach angaben der
un flüchtlingshilfe waren im jahr 2018
weltweit 70,8 millionen menschen auf der
flucht
anders als die afg versuchen wir nicht
mit polemik sondern mit
rechtsstaatlichen mitteln den
vielfältigen anforderungen gerecht zu
werden
denn die politik der cdu csu fraktion
bekennt sich zu den grundsätzen des
christlichen menschenbildes wir sind
deshalb aufgefordert menschen zu helfen
die verfolgt oder auch durch den
bürgerkrieg in lebensgefahr geraten sind
gleichzeitig können wir aber nicht die
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen probleme
weltweit lösen sondern mit klugen
ansätzen hilfe zur selbsthilfe und damit
für linderung für den einzelnen dem
herkunftsland sorgen aber auch dem
christlichen menschenbild ist die
freiheit des einzelnen nicht grenzenlos
flüchtlinge die in deutschland aufnahme
gefunden haben
und sei es nur auf zeit müssen sich wie
alle bürger hierzulande an recht und
gesetz halten integration erschöpft sich
nicht darin deutsch zu lernen und
selbstständig für seinen lebensunterhalt
zu sorgen ein bekenntnis zu unserer
werteordnung zu unserem fundament
unserer rechtsstaatlichen gesellschaft
gehört ebenfalls dazu
wer bereit ist sich in diesem sinne zu
integrieren bekommt eine faire chance in
unserem land der seinen beitrag auch in
zukunft für eine entwicklung für eine
positive entwicklung unseres landes
leisten kann
dafür herzlichen dankeschön herzliches
vergelt's gott sagt florian oßner und
die debatte über den antrag der fdp
kommt langsam zum ende die letzte
rednerin ist jetzt cool ist ein wechsel
von den sozialdemokraten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren vor dem
bildschirm auf den tribünen liebe
kollegen kollegen die acht wieder einmal
über migrationspolitik sprechen und
aufgaben für integrationsleistungen
flucht ursachenbekämpfung oder
registrierungsverfahren im
bundeshaushalt sind die einzelnen
positionen bereits seit jahren fein
säuberlich aufgelistet
darüber hinaus fast jährlich bericht
fach ein jährlicher bericht die
massnahmen des bundes unterstützung im
bereich der flüchtlings- und
integrationskosten zusammen
die art
plötzlich trotz all der
kostenaufstellungen nicht um fassung
informiert das ist verständlich denn ein
wichtiger aspekt wird übersehen oder
ihnen unterschlagen vielmehr und dass
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ist der wert der migration
gerne komme ich also ihrem anliegen
ihres antrages nach und erklären ihnen
wie wertvoll migration ist mein vater
kam mitte der sechziger jahre
wie viele andere gastarbeiter nach
deutschland deutschland wurde zu einem
einwanderungsland und gleichzeitig für
viele zu neuen heimat so auch für mich
als achtjähriges mädchen reiste ich aus
der türkei zu meinem vater in das für
mich damals noch sehr fremde land
deutschland mittlerweile ist bereits die
vierte generation der gastarbeiter
herangewachsen die kinder und enkel sind
ein fester teil der bevölkerung sie lebt
meist bewusst mit zwei kulturen in einer
in der bundesrepublik die offener und
vielfältiger geworden ist sie gestalten
dieses land auf vielen ebenen und vielen
bereichen mit das ist wertvoll
[Applaus]
die reaktion der geflüchteten ist
natürlich ungleich dramatischer fliehen
sie doch vor krieg vertreibung und
klimakatastrophen aber auch geflüchtete
gehören zu unserer gesellschaft und
leisten ihren beitrag
so waren ende letzten jahres bereits
245.000 menschen aus asyl
herkunftsländern
sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftigt
viele engagieren sich darüber hinaus für
andere auch das ist wertvoll
insgesamt sanken migranten übrigens
überdurchschnittlich gründungs aktiv sie
stellen in deutschland jeden fünften
gründer sie schaffen damit viele
arbeitsplätze und leisten einen beitrag
für unsere wirtschaft und auch das ist
sehr wertvoll
liebe kollegen kollegen bei allem
wirtschaftlichen nutzen ihrer
innovations- und arbeitskraft dürfen wir
menschen jedoch niemals nur als
kostenfaktor sehen wer so denkt wird ein
trauriges dasein
wer sich das essen zum wert der
solidarität bekennt kann seinem leben
sinn geben um es mit den worten des
französischen philosophen albert kam ihm
zu sagen gegen die absurdität des lebens
hilft nur die menschliche solidarität
heute gehören zu unserer
solidargemeinschaft in deutschland
menschen aus mehr als 150 nationen mit
unterschiedlichen kulturen religionen
und erfahrungen
diese vielfalt und solidarität ist ein
gewinn für unser land und macht uns
stark
ich selbst lebe nun seit 50 jahren hier
ich bin hier zur schule gegangen habe
meine ausbildung absolviert habe mir ein
arbeits und privatleben aufgebaut und
mich politisch engagiert und
gesellschaftlich heute bin ich
abgeordnete im deutschen bundestag
ich bin stolz nicht für unser land
einsetzen zu dürfen
ich bin auch stolz ihnen hier den berg
der migration näher zu bringen
ich gerne hören wollen die
demokratischen kräfte werden nicht
aufhören sie daran zu erinnern wie
wertvoll eine vielfältige und
solidarische gesellschaft ist herzlichen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
damit schließe ich die aussprache